yeah welcome to a new video playing
international mass of an empire gala
played plenty of numerous times just a
couple of games before heading as well
so we got the ratty gambit and well the
best mm yeah let's go Bishop f5 I have
some ID am queen bee three there's a new
idea with knight c6 and Bishop d7 which
is some are quite tricky for white but i
don't really know itself yeah this is a
bit dumb a bit dicey you to play that
just that some front recently told me
that this would be good okay that's just
to play
the most aggressive moves that come to
mind okay 94 maybe i should i should
actually improve a bit before i play
that d for Queen one what should I do
here maybe yeah just threaten deform
grab got the good development this is
Sir this is all the question
yeah just Bishop c5 a it's got d3
attacking attacking the pawn chain
maybe maybe still go down yeah the bad
thing is this is actually relatively
easy for white to play what probably
doesn't have a great position or
something but he's got easy moves get
stuff developed cannot take here really
is this too too slow yeah of course
playing instantly okay default yeah I
don't have enough him by far I mean I'm
very far away from having enough
compensation oh I actually thought this
always sized mossy fibers hanging it saw
that see if I was hanging I mean c6
singing queen here after come on again I
cannot do anything else anyway oh I
didn't see that one coming
hmm
yeah is unfortunately protecting the
Queen on a for this is just a piece yeah
this was an opening disaster yeah
actually okay first time yeah I can
resign here here cut the wrong button um
yeah it's I have okay maybe you
shouldn't sacrifice pawns if you have no
idea how how i discontinued but i mean
this this looks like it could be
something i'm pretty sure maybe even a
shot play night before I'd really Center
the Queen bag yeah this is probably not
great yeah it's also so easy to play I
mean what else he only has got those
moves you can play them instantly and I
don't know what the best move and I need
to spend time because for black it's not
so so easy you have good development but
what actually are you attacking why it
just makes the simple moves anyone can
play and it's not not great yeah
probably here it's um it's already over
in terms of decent compensation because
a man cannot take and I have no move
actually I mean this was relatively best
problem this this then assess this is
over I cannot play d4 or something yeah
this was just an opening disaster it
rarely happens but proof sometimes it
does yeah thanks for watching